The capabilities operation in the whole system section retrieves
the server's capability statement resource
describing its current operational functionality.
As shown here, using
Graham Greeves interesting tabular presentation for human consumption,
clients connecting to a FHIR server can use the capabilities
interaction to check whether they are version and or feature compatible with the server.
Beyond this, FHIR provides a set of resources to represent and share
the adaptations made in a particular server in a computable fashion.
Adaptations might include restrictions such as
allowed values within a value set specified in the standard.
Alternatively, they might specify another value set that is more
expensive or that it is necessary in a special context.
For example, the value sets for the specification of ethnicity differ among countries.
Data elements can be required and extensions can be added.
This set of resources form the conformance module as shown here.
The conformance resources can be used in isolation but they are typically used in
the context of an Implementation Guide as shown in the center of this diagram.
Implementation Guides are documents published by a domain, institution,
or vendor that described how FHIR is
adapted to support a certain use case or set of use cases.
An Implementation Guide combines a set of conformance resources
and supporting narrative into a document to be used by implementors.
A good example of an Implementation Guide is the DAF,
Data Access Framework to the FHIR specification that specifies access to
patient data for EHR systems to meet
the requirements of meaningful use and related federal regulations.